مظاهره تمثل عوده للمظاهرات الحاشده في
قلب العاصمه البريطانيه لندن بحسب الشرطه
البريطانيه عشرات الالاف شاركوا في بدايه
هذه الظاهره وما زالت الاعداد تتزايد كما
تشاهدون هناك تنوع كبير في يعني خلفيات
المشاركين سواء العرقيه او العمريه وايضا
الانتماءات هناك افراد عاديون وهناك
الكثيرون او الكثير من النقابات التي
تشارك في هذا او في هذه التظاهر التي تجوب
قلب العاصمه البريطانيه لمسافه حوالي 4
كيلومترات او اكثر دعونا ان نحاول ان
نستطلع اراء بعض المشاركين في هذه
التظاهر نطالب بوقف اطلاق النار فورا
وبتطبيق حل الدولتين وبحريه
للفلسطينيين نقول لقادتنا السياسيين انتم
تدعمون اسرائيل في تنفيذ الاباده الجماعيه
بحق الفلسطينيين ولن نتوقف عن الاحتجاج
حتى تتوقفوا عن التواطؤ مع اسرائيل
وتوقفوا دعمكم الماليه والدبلوماسيه
والعسكريه لاسرائيل
وامام مقر الحكومه البريطانيه في لندن
تجمع المتظاهرون الان يقدر المنظمون اعداد
المشاركين في هذه المظاهره بنحو 200 الف
الهتافات واللافتات كلها تحمل رسالات
واضحه اوقفوا الاباده الجماعيه في غزه
اوقفوا اطلاق النار فورا حاسبوا اسرائيل
واقفوا دعمها سياسيا وعسكريا
ودبلوماسيا اسد الله الصاوي الجزيره
لندن